let's do it we got this story from
msn.com bricks gold-backed common
currency a shock to Global Fiat money
system says Economist as Russia confirms
launch in August oh boy is this one
esoteric I'm sure many of it home are
like yo I don't even know why I clicked
the link to this video because I have no
idea what you're talking about I'm sure
many of you who are in the know saw the
headline and went holy crap and I'm sure
most of you who are really in the no sad
Tim we already knew this but bear with
me this is big news brics is the
principal rival to basically nato in the
western powers
the world operates on the US dollar as
its Reserve currency you want to buy oil
you use U.S dollars with bricks
launching this currency backed by gold
they're basically giving a massive
middle finger to the US and telling all
the countries in the world our money
actually means something theirs does not
further we've already seen countries
like Saudi Arabia trying to do deals
with China or actually doing them to
trade oil in one
this means we are inching ever closer to
the U.S no longer having the reserve
currency and you know what that means
that means all of you at home you're
going to see your standard of living
drop dramatically and therein lies the
double double-edged sword when it comes
to International Politics the United
States does not export enough we export
culture movies music sure but other
countries can do that other countries
can export a lot of stuff so what do we
really provide to be honest military
might when we want oil we print the
dollars we buy the oil when any other
country wants oil they need to buy
dollars from us from us first with this
deal from bricks that basically shuts
down our International Ponzi scheme or
whatever you want to call it and then
all of a sudden we have nothing to trade
what will the U.S trade for brics
currency that's the big question what
are we manufacturing what are we
exporting that bricks would want so that
they would give us gold back currency
that we could use to buy oil with yeah
so here's my here's here's my here's my
fear and a lot of other people's fears
the reason why the Deep State the
bureaucratic State the the neolibs the
neocons want war is to make sure we
don't lose this status so the likelihood
that we enter into a dramatically
escalated conflict is ever ever so
increasing to the point where let me
tell you how desperate the machine has
become
earlier last year or so I think it was
last year when Russia started using was
accused of using cluster bombs the U.S
the Western forces claimed that was
potentially a war crime now the West has
become so desperate that Joe Biden has
approved the sending of cluster bombs to
Ukrainian forces something that they had
previously said could be a war crime
this is what I'm talking about the
people saying oh you can't do that
because that's evil and wrong and then a
year later being like if we lose this
we're done for so just do it anyway how
far off are we from someone saying yeah
well nukes are no longer off the table
yeah I don't know it's a very
frightening situation all I really have
to say about it is this to quote the
venerable Archbishop folt machine if a
nation would behave more justly if it
were conquered it should expect to be
conquered in the United States has not
been a nation which operated in a moral
way domestically or on the international
stage in a very long time I've seen some
of that turning around I think the
overturner over Roe v Wade and the fact
that we've saved tens of thousands of
children has been incredible I think
there's been massive backlash against
the lgbtq agenda more young people are
waking up and seeing the farce of the
sexual Revolution But ultimately this
country has a lot of problems and uh I
hope that we can pull through them I
hope that the United States can be a
strong dominant nation that behaves
morally but that's not the track we've
placed ourselves on over the past 50 or
60 years so
I uh I hope for good things but I don't
know that I necessarily expect them
I mean considering the the the fact that
the the brics currency is it's already
in motion it's not something that's
being talked about anymore
um it feels like the writing's on the
wall that they you know the Petro dollar
is the time is is limited and I mean
people need to plan accordingly you know
if if we're in as much debt as we are to
China and to to other countries and
stuff in our national debts like it is
and we lose the value the the status as
the reserve currency of the world
interest rates are going to keep going
up and the buying power of your dollar
is going to keep going down and so and
it's going to have a massive effect on
the average person so it it
unfortunately these things are it's slow
moving so a lot of people have kind of
you know shut the idea of of a currency
crisis out because it has been something
that P they've you've heard people
talking about it since like 2008 you
know like since the the
the financial crisis people have been
talking about oh if you keep printing
money then there'll be inflation Etc and
we're in debt and I feel like the
average person is kind of be kind of
just gone numb to that and if people are
numb to it and they haven't been
preparing for it or they don't
it's going to come back and bite him in
the ass and as usual the the poor people
in the US and people on the margins you
know people that are just making it are
going to fall into poverty and people
that are already poor they're you know
they're going to be screwed and to be
clear the the point I want to make here
is that I hope that doesn't happen right
again I hope the United States is able
to maintain our status as World Reserve
currency and we turn a corner and start
behaving more morally with respect to
our conduct both in on the foreign stage
and domestically and and there's
actually some precedent to think that
that might happen just based on the last
year or two in the way some things have
improved in some areas but yeah I mean
this if we lose World Reserve currency
status if this country continues to
spend and print money in unsustainable
ways and also get involved in conflicts
we have no business being involved in
um I think it's probably fair to say
that we're not going to be able to
sustain that and just like any nation
that starts fooling around because they
become powerful and hubris stick we're
going to end up seeing our own collapse
but what if
the Democratic nominee for president and
the debate says
here's what we're going to do
we're going to invade Ukraine we're
going to uh in order to fight the Russia
like I should say invade Ukraine but
we're going to send booze on the ground
to Ukraine boots on the ground in Syria
we're going to build a corridor through
Syria turkey into the into Europe to
offset the Russian gas Monopoly and we
are going to do these things
specifically to destroy the economies of
the brics Nations to prevent them from
subverting the world Reserve currency
what if they just flat out came out and
said this is what we're doing and why
we're doing it because our economy is
propped up by the fact that we print
money and we don't export and the only
thing we can do is point guns to the
rest of the world and tell them that
they must serve us and all of your
computers and all of your components the
materials in there are mined by children
who are working as slaves
you can have that or you can live in
squalor
make your pick
what do you do not the average person
would would decide to they'd vote for
they I think they vote for the machine
in two seconds and make an excuse I I
think well the machine makes excuses for
itself right so I think the way it's
going to be advertised to the American
people is there's some human rights
atrocity or violation that's occurring
in these countries so now we have to go
step in and intervene
that's what they're doing now but I
think the issue is
when they were like cluster bombs or a
potential War crime and then Joe Biden's
like well might as well send cluster
bombs it's like okay
that's not going to work you're not
going to be able to go and say look a
war crime is happening and then we're
going to go ahead and do the same thing
that propaganda is not going to work
regular people might just lie to
themselves to justify why we should be
in war but
man what do you think I don't know the
whole thing is scary to me of course I
mean there's not a good option either
way as far as what you just said I don't
I mean
I don't know it's all doom and gloom you
know I mean in in reference to what you
said about Tim bouda cluster bombs and
stuff I mean the Vietnam War started in
1954 I think is when and the French were
kind of doing most of the the combat
role there and doing most of the
fighting and the US didn't actually
really get involved until 64. and then
it was a whole another 10 years
it's completely reasonable to say that
you know we're a year and change in on
the on the the war in Ukraine or
whatever and all this stuff that we said
we weren't going to send all of these
things that that the government said
they weren't going to be doing they keep
coming and coming back and saying okay
well you know now we're going to so
there's there's no actual line that the
U.S won't Cross or at least that that we
as a population can reliably say okay we
believe the government won't do this the
government has demonstrated over and
over that they'll say one thing and as
soon as it you know it comes time to be
what they deem a necessity you know they
say we need to we need to go ahead and
do this for this reason it's completely
expected or or should be expected that
if the U.S has said no we're not going
to do this if the conditions on the
ground demand it or or can an argument
can be made that the conditions on the
ground on demand it they're going to do
it and I think that is up to and
including a nuclear exchange with Russia
if if it gets to that point now I'm I'm
not saying that it will
but if you put Americans on the ground
in Ukraine
I could see that happening and I don't
see the off ramp for this to get to get
us out of of eventually sending people
to fight in Ukraine this is this is why
I bring this up this is the Tit for Tad
we say oh no cluster bombs you can't do
that then we do cluster bombs they start
producing an international gold back
currency we have this here take a look
at this William middle Coop says 41
countries have applied for bricks
membership this is massive this is what
what is this like just about a third of
the world yeah and I mean not many in
our government but well maybe with China
too many in government I mean these are
fighting words saying that we are going
to use a currency absolutely that is not
controlled by the United States of
America something that's very
frightening for those uh in the ruling
Elite here and to be frank it's those
are frightening words for your average
person too if they really consider them
because if we do lose our status as
World Reserve currency the quality of
life is going to diminish for basically
everybody in this country now you gotta
imagine the position that foreign
leaders are in and foreign nations are
in they see how we have absolutely
abused our status as World Reserve
currency and the fact that people need
to trade in our dollar and are compelled
to by the way the market functions
currently
in 2020 when covid-19
crippled our economy or at the very
least I should say when the lockdowns
and the overreaction to covid-19
crippled our economy what our government
did is they responded by engaging in the
most gigantic transfer of wealth that
has ever occurred in all of human
history and they gave virtually all of
the money to the wealthiest people in
this nation and devalued the currency of
everyone who had Savings in order to
engage in that transfer of wealth now
anyone who was paying attention at that
time said this is going to massively
harm those in the lower classes this
massively going to harm people who have
saved and this is also going to harm
people who own small businesses because
the SBA was expected to handle something
like 10 times its yearly budget over the
course of a month or two weeks in order
to get this bailout money to small
businesses now the giant businesses that
got what 4.2 trillion in low interest
loans
we're able to leverage that to purchase
up a lot of those smaller businesses
after they closed down and it was done
with your currency being devalued now
poor and working-class people don't have
a whole lot of recourse for that but you
know who does have a lot of recourse for
that
rich people in other nations who were
holding U.S currency who didn't get that
payout as well as oligarchs in rulers of
other countries that have stashed U.S
dollars because they had some faith that
the United States dollar was going to
carry its value over into the future and
many of them are saying you know what
we're probably going to use our clout to
punish the American dollar and punish
people who are in control of it by
pulling out and signing on to some new
currency thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time